[Music]
in kid banker news food banker it's a
bit about cash these days bread
ketchup al whoa a young man founded his
own bank when he was only seven years
old huh
whoa let's be nice that's like blank
check my mat movie yeah and he wrote
himself a check for a million dollars
and he built he bought bought a castle I
know like no way like I know it was the
90s well was he in California cuz yeah
right but if he was maybe like he wasn't
California wasn't he I think he was I
believed it oh yeah right he had like a
butler and I was on Leno and his own
didn't yeah but you don't talk about you
something like that so such a child the
biggest amount of money that was a
million it was a lot in the manga it's a
lot now it's still a lot right now come
on guys people like watching this eating
Taco Bell the only family bought on the
dollar menu and they're like you guys
know but I'm saying all those things you
can't buy it with a million now you
can't even buy a two-bedroom in Studio
City you wouldn't have been able to buy
a castle with a million back event
either no way all right so this story is
about who say he's from Peru no she is
about 13 years old now but he started
his bank for students only like his bank
is only for kids it's like the Facebook
of banks
yeah because before it was only first
dude in yeah the students can't pay the
money back so he's a genius like this
kid is so [ __ ] smart make me feel bad
about myself
come on yes I'm going to make you do it
oh when he so he founded this Bank after
he realized that there were like he saw
a lot of his classmates that they would
just like spend money on things that
they need or like candy or things like
which most children will do for sure
they didn't know how to save and like
they just ended not only that but they
always had to be reliant on their
parents for money or some of these kids
were so poor that they had to work for
themselves and like actually make their
own money on their own the lemonade
stands were going out of business means
like you guys gotta save the [ __ ] and so
he came up with the idea of having this
Bank where these kids these
these clients of this bank they would
turn in at least five cute kilograms of
recycled waste which would be paper or
plastic he partnered up with his
recycling center where they would up
like the percentage a little bit more
for like his clients yeah they would try
to turn in the trash or their
recyclables and they end up getting
money deposited and their bacon only the
child can withdraw like the parents
can't withdraw the money at all and that
was how that this Bank started and but
now it's grown to the point where now he
offers like different financial he's
given loans and stuff and like charging
interest he has a variety of financial
products so like like loans capital
investment micro insurance and then
access to financial education through a
series of courses Papeete know like any
client that wants to sign up to this
bank they first have to take this course
such trash dude this course I'm like how
to shave in like a financial course if
you don't pay his loans back there's a
dad come and beat you up he's like my
dad will come and kick your ass you
really shouldn't you really should pay
me I love the adults that took the 7
year old serious like the recycle he's
saying that a lot of those teachers and
like front like everyone around was just
like there's no way like this is this
task is too big for you little
seven-year-old kid don't worry about
this don't do this the dream crusher 7
that's crazy well now he's 13 so yeah
he's been in business for six years yeah
it's crazy
holy [ __ ] and now I think he has like
look he's like a vlogger too you see
that [ __ ] with the camera no that's it I
bet the business courses probably a
video probably no thank you also he's
even got a chance to meet the Queen like
the you know queen the loser stream okay
room no I said Elizabeth completely
ignorant he met the Queen like when he
was like 13
no I think he was
younger than that well I don't know cuz
there's there's a lot of elizabeth's and
there's a lot of Queens wait like the
only queen the world cares about clean I
don't know that whoa diss it all the
other Queen Queen Latifah just got just
like crying she was like come on yeah
this kid is [ __ ] dope so he has Isaac
with piece of [ __ ] huh do you make you
look like absolute trash bro cuz I'm
gonna dull what you do with your life
I'll tell you this I work with this
company called just kidding news it's
awesome
what a joke what a joke that all of us
are on this right now this kid made that
revenue his first year yeah usually kids
like this come from really fucked-up
families and I don't know how he did it
he's awesome aside because he saw how
[ __ ] up your lives were he's like I'm
not gonna do this yeah he wants it when
he grows up he wants to run for
president he wants to change parolees do
it 90 starting from like by teaching the
children all children like the
importance of saving that's amazing yeah
because they're like if everyone just
learned to save their money or like -
like distribute it very like smartly
like you know make better TV should take
his course I'm gonna take this course
that's amazing yeah then like their
country would come on you know that's
actually the economy is better when
people spend yeah you can spend on
investments hey and I wonder why they
don't teach us how to save in school
interesting cuz the more we blow money
the more we buy things
damn straight they teach that in school
you just don't listen no dog they do not
yes they do if you take they teach you
how to spend yes they do that's what
they do they tell you like oh you have
four quarters and like two down go get a
credit card they're super useful
everybody needs a credit card
don't forget well you do it to build
credit right but that's our that's where
system is this exact what I'm getting at
yeah I [ __ ] bought a cart that you
could push in sand what I don't know why
are you having Joe Fox's I would never
buy something that's stupid
it's because when you go to the beach
you can't push the cart so you need
bigger wheels so I bought that oh that
sounds dope so I I have it in my in my
house and I'm like [ __ ] am I gonna go to
beach cuz like if you go and you want to
lug a bunch of stuff exactly like that
yeah cuz we got a carry yeah wait till
you have to drag it in a box wait what's
happening it's a cart that has a handle
but the regular ones don't work because
it won't go on sand rags what regular
ones like the regular carpet I have at
the office the blue one
the one that I always use so many beach
carts like a wagon thing do you go to
the beach a lot of carts so I went once
and then I was like I saw somebody else
with it I was like that's [ __ ] smart
now I've been back to the beach in a
very long so you're like Bart you bought
like a [ __ ] ton of gear for something to
do one that's what Joe does too it's
great not anymore
yeah you think cuz you don't let me
clean that's awesome
I would if you'd let me uh you have
control of your own goddamn my [ __ ] he's
like I would blow my money if you would
let me if you would stop laughing at me
yeah it pains me when I get fun things
it does not you're such a liar
he's such a martyr I love it he's maybe
he makes his own fight I don't you know
it pays me when I get fun things it's
hard as he blows his instruments control
over him come on he's like I'm a slave
to my own success you need you have some
kind of mind control room no control
over this man none whatsoever I don't
buy that have you ever walked around
your house butt naked and demanded
things out of them yeah he doesn't care
anymore
I walk around naked and eat indicator
that's cuz you fart and yeah you can't
do that well I fart now cuz you stop
caring what came first the fart or the
care they care they care came way
oh yeah looky first thank you
I only just started farting a lot like
in the last couple months because I've
been on a high-protein diet okay because
she doesn't know it but while I'm here
play with my toys is she talking [ __ ]
about it makes me not want to play with
it anymore
the toys are making you sad now Joe
all these little 10 year old fans of
yours are gonna start spamming my [ __ ]
they're gonna believe the bad woman made
him hate his toy I'll tell you this
though you do have somewhat control
because if it was up to Joe he'd be
playing those annoying as instruments at
your house that's the only control is
that the instruments are not allowed
yeah I can only sing like tiptoeing
around like now like funeral song hams
are good you do have control I think
women have a lot more control over the
men than they think
I agree completely Abby that's why I
don't change in front of him now it's
like that's not fair crazy don't punish
me because I like it I know that do you
think that he would get tired of seeing
the tittays you know we wear off you
know I went to the strip oh you were
there well woman's a strip club it's
like after like but those aren't titties
that they love though those are just
titties in it there I mean that's
completely different so John I've seen
there's so many titties I was like I'm
so sick of these I still think a little
bit of mystery a little bit of mystery
and then I'm swimming I know cousin that
before we went to see the strip club or
was it the night of we saw humanity
whose same night that was a lot of weird
hella horny so we were like another club
or dippy gamble that night it was all in
one night I think oh no no that wasn't
okay that was the night before
yeah because were you watching my Kojak
last night that we were there we played
yeah I would say craps we went to the
strip club and then the next day we saw
titties but it wasn't as intense as the
first that's right so we already [ __ ]
it up yeah yeah we should have [ __ ]
warmed up to it yeah you don't eat the
dessert and then the steak and then the
salad that's right by the time you get
to the salad you like it get the [ __ ]
[ __ ] away from there like I wish I put
some clothes out while she does acrobats
right look at the hey [ __ ] put upon your
clothes
welcome trash you loose woman loose
women the titties I saw yesterday were
better than that disgusting you were
able to touch them I didn't touch did I
it wasn't memorable anyway we were
talking about this kid banker but we
could always get two titties this is why
we have it opened our own bank all right
just like that's for sure cuz I get
distracted by titties there you go
I want to know how he did this I know
yeah he did have the support of his
parents obviously and then there's this
one teacher like a teacher's assistant
teacher that believed in him this is a
movie I want to see movie from this for
sure yeah but this is one of the movie
were like the wait till he becomes like
rich and powerful and like just [ __ ]
jealous president of Peru
what the movie starts with he's 7 years
old and then he's still like 7 years old
to get older Yeah right where's the we
have to wait for him to get older yes
I'm saying
no it's gonna be a rise informant
[Music]
Oh